malo I'm Gabrielle Calliphora i live in
Cuba please come in
that's me this one living room I
entertain friends here but I also work
here and this is my desk so young
bhagwan think i'm a bit old-fashioned I
always write my hand am on the great
works of world literature were also
written by hand lebanon's the first
surah of the Quran it says that there is
only one God Allah yo scarce Allah
I guess a warning that's an original
there the small pictures are copies
rondo when my mother died in Denmark I
found them among her things there by
Danish artists who had lived in Italy
the KBB Aaron and Natalya
the whole now this is a Korean lamp that
I've had for many years would I took it
with me to Europe and then it came back
here with me conmigo y they got a saw
yo baby though I've lived and worked in
a lot of countries nunca más and I never
felt like a stranger they wound all the
other right from the second day whether
in delhi Tokyo or New York I've always
felt it home it's in kokomo see you wear
a baby though I eat a la la vida 10
thank you for your interest in my heart
Delta until the next Tommy I hope we'll
see each other again soon in Cuba